We love superhero movies, but sometimes filmmakers
seem to think that because the movies feature
superheroes, they don't have to feature logic
or reason.
From hiding critical clues in the stupidest
places to plain old boneheaded plot holes,
here are some superhero movie moments that
make absolutely no sense.
Howard Stark's terrible clues
Iron Man 2 was bloated to begin with, but
the big twist was one of the dumbest plot
points possible.
Tony discovers the new element he needs at
just the right time thanks to clues hidden
by his dear old dead dad, Howard.
"I built this for you and some day you'll
realize it represents a whole lot more than
people's inventions.
It represents my life's work."
That's incredibly lucky timing, especially
considering Howard hid his clues in one of
the most random ways possible, embedding a
cryptic message to Tony in an old home movie
reel — which then unlocks an even more cryptic
clue hidden inside the old Stark EXPO design.
But considering the clues were being kept
top secret by Nick Fury himself, couldn't
Howard have just, you know… written Tony
a letter with the info?
Or maybe just a note on the fridge?
That would've been way, way easier to find.
Why not use Quicksilver all the time?
Introducing a speedster can make for awesome
effects and cool set pieces.
But it also creates more than a few plot problems,
as viewers of X-Men: Days of Future Past found
out.
Sure, the Quicksilver super-speed scene is
easily the coolest moment in a very good movie.
But, why on Earth would Professor X sideline
Quicksilver for the rest of the movie after
getting a peek at his abilities?
Quicksilver can take out every enemy in the
movie before they even know they're in a fight.
But after getting Quicksilver to help free
Magneto, Xavier and future Wolverine just…
send him back to his basement for the rest
of the film.
That seems not so smart.
Why wait for the House Party?
Fans might be mixed on Iron Man 3, but there's
no denying the film did a great job of putting
Tony Stark outside his comfort zone and telling
a story unlike pretty much every other Iron
Man movie.
We just have one head-scratcher: Why didn't
he just pull out the "House Party" protocol
sooner and get that army of super-suits out
of their hidey holes?
He spends most of the film trying to repair
and reacquire his latest suit, but he apparently
has an emergency protocol all this time that
can get an army of autonomous Iron Guys in
the air.
Why not flip that lever a while back?
Yes, they needed to excavate the mansion to
get a path cleared, but it doesn't take that
long to just cut a man-sized hole down to
the lab, does it?
Logos without logic
It's hard to deny that Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice was a bloated mess, and one
of the film's biggest problems is that it
tries to shoehorn in all sorts of setup for
Justice League at the expense of the Batman
versus Superman story.
The most ridiculous example?
When Diana is checking out Lex Luthor's super
secret disk drive, she finds files on pretty
much all the future Justice League members
— complete with little logos that Lex apparently
designed for them in his free time — and
then spends five minutes watching the equivalent
of a bunch of YouTube clips while Gotham and
Metropolis are being ravaged by super-villains.
C'mon, lady, focus up!
The 'Francis' conundrum
One of the big jokes in Deadpool is the fact
that Wade sneakily figures out that Ajax's
real name is Francis, then proceeds to call
him that just to piss him off.
"With a name like Francis…"
"Francis?"
"That's his legal name.
He got Ajax from the dish soap."
When Wade gets loose later and sets off on
his revenge mission, he starts hunting down
all of Ajax's known associates by asking for
Francis.
It's great!
And funny!
Except since the entire point is that Ajax
doesn't want anyone to know his real name,
none of the people Deadpool is torturing should
have any idea who he's talking about.
If Deadpool had simply told any of them that
he was looking for Ajax, rather than Francis,
maybe the whole movie could have been wrapped
up in under 15 minutes.
Fortunately for fans, it wasn't.
Batman's healing factor
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy is
one of the seminal film franchises in comic
book history, but even the mighty Nolan can
stretch things a bit too far.
Case in point: the fact that old man Batman
in The Dark Knight Rises is somehow stronger
and more physically capable than any version
of the Dark Knight we've seen up until then,
despite having a busted knee and a broken
back.
Not to mention he's been a retired invalid
for almost a decade, meaning he should be
woefully out of shape.
Yet, one appointment with a prison chiropractor
later, and Bruce goes from super couch potato
to unbeatable.
One popular orb
Marvel's Guardians the Galaxy is so darn fun
that it's hard to actually nitpick much of
anything.
But watch it a few times and the seams start
to show.
One of the biggest is the point that actually
kicks off the whole movie: Star-Lord's trip
to Morag to retrieve that orb, which is actually
an Infinity Stone.
If this thing is in such high demand, why
hasn't anyone retrieved it before?
And what kind of crazy coincidence is it that
after being ignored for untold centuries,
everyone literally shows up at the exact same
moment looking for it?
"How do you know about this?"
I don't even know it is, I'm just a junker,
man.
Just che-checking stuff out."
Director James Gunn tried to handwave this
in the commentary track, saying the planet
has tidal seasons that last hundreds of years,
so everyone is showing up because this is
the first time the orb hasn't been underwater
in 300 years.
That unlikely explanation might get him a
No-Prize from Marvel, but since it's not actually
in the movie, it doesn't really count.
"Congratulations!
You're another lucky no-prize winner.
You'll find it enclosed, enclosed.
They'd open it up, the envelope was empty."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!